HANK PYM
Scott, you have a chance to be the hero...
...and earn that look
in your daughter's eyes.
When you came back...
...everything changed.
The doorway to the
Quantum Realm has opened.
♪♪
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You may be an Avenger...
...but you're out of
your league, Ant-Man.
JANET VAN DYNE
This place, it changes you.
It made a monster
who thinks he's a god.
SCOTT LANG
I don't care who this guy is,
we're gonna go home.
HOPE VAN DYNE
We'll stop him together.
CASSIE LANG
Dad!
KANG THE CONQUEROR
You think you can beat me?
I am Kang!
HOPE VAN DYNE
You ready?
SCOTT LANG
Ready.
[Screaming]
SCOTT LANG
Momentum, right? Jump, tap!
You see what I did?
CASSIE LANG
No, you're like this small!